5 46 on your friday morning there is a  fast approaching deadline for families  and some special schools  out of the clark county school  district's 300 000 plus students more  than 10 percent of them are in magnet  schools with a wide variety of special  programs ranging from the arts to  finance from math and science to medical  training  there are 10 magnet elementaries 13  magnet middle schools 10 magnet high  schools and seven career technical  academy high schools a ton of  information about all of them at  magnet.ccsd.net  for now though the most important piece  of information may be this the deadline  to apply for the magnet schools it's  next tuesday january 11. now maybe  didn't catch that web address it's in  the online version of this story on our  website and if you know something that's  cool at school let us know on our  8newsnow.com website under the community  tab or just email us cool at school at 8  news now dot com